[Music]
I think first the realization that there
are lots of different religions and they
can't all be right and the Christian one
in which I was brought up was clearly
only one of many but that didn't finally
make me into an atheist what finally
made me into an atheist was the
realization that there was no scientific
reason to believe in any sort of
supernatural creator that came with the
understanding of Darwinian evolution
the sense of faith has meaning belief in
something for which there is no evidence
there is a sense there are various
senses of faith in which we do
scientists do participate those branches
of science which I don't understand for
example physics I it could be said I
suppose that I have faith that
physicists understand it better than I
do and so when I say something that
physicists tell me such as that that
there was nothing before the Big Bang
are not allowed to talk about about the
word before in the context of the Big
Bang I sort of have faith that
physicists understand enough to be
allowed to say that even though I don't
understand why they're allowed to say
that but it's not faith it's not blind
faith it's not faith in the absence of
evidence it's faith that's based upon
confidence in the scientific method in
scientific peer review process the fact
that I know that there are other
physicists who can test verify criticize
the views of any one physicist so it's
not the same as as religious faith which
is which is based upon no evidence at
all
well it's certainly true that so many
people do have religious faith not just
individual people not all individual
people do but all cultures I think I'm
right in saying that all peoples in the
plural have had faith religious faith of
some kind they believe in some kind of
supernatural gods or goddesses or
leprechauns or whatever it might be why
do they have it well I think it's very
tempting when you're you don't really
understand what's going on when you're
ignorant of the world when you find
yourself surrounded by a wonderful world
a puzzling world a mysterious world a
frightening world it must be quite
tempting to put your faith into a
supernatural being of some kind
[Music]